اشتباكات وصفت بالاعنف شهدتها الخرطوم في
اليوم العشرين على اندلاع القتال بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
تركزت هذه الاشتباكات في محيط القصر
الجمهوري واستخدمت فيها اسلحه ثقيله
ومتوسطه كما شن سلاح الطيران السوداني
غارات كثيفه على محيط القصر واجهتها
المضادات الجويه للدعم السريع المشهد تكرر
في الخرطوم بحري اذ شنت طائرات الجيش ايضا
غارات كثيفه على اهداف شماليه المنطقه
تصدت لها مضادات قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني قال في بيان له ان قواته اشتبكت
مع من وصفهم بالمتمردين وصدت هجومهم على
قياده منطقه بحر العسكريه وتحديدا قياده
سلاح الاشاره واستطاعت تشتيت قواتهم
وتدمير عدد من المركبات العسكريه ومصادره
عدد اخر منها من جانبها قالت قوات الدعم
السريع في بيان لها ان الجيش هاجمها في
عدد من مواقع تمركزها في العاصمه الخرطوم
بالمدفعيه والطائرات وقالت ان احياء سكنيه
تعرضت لقصف عشوائي عنيف في مسلك يشكل
تجاوزا سافرا للاعراف والقوانين الدوليه
بحسب تعبير البيان